que nous avons consacré à la mairie en
font une des effectifs la parole est à
monsieur julien aubert merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à madame
le ministre des affaires sociales il ya
quasiment deux ans le 20 novembre 2014
je vous avais interrogé sur l'avenir
d'une maternité apte dans le luberon
pour laquelle les habitants se battent
depuis vingt ans ma vie répondu que le
choix du gouvernement n'était pas de
fermer les petits établissements et de
pénaliser les hôpitaux de proximité
contrairement à la droite vous m'aviez
expliqué que l'avenir de la maternité
des lilas des enjeux de sécurité en
précisant qu'une mission composée
d'experts se pencher sur le sujet et que
le résultat de leur travail seraient
connus en décembre 2014 les artésiens
ont cru votre parole madame le ministre
et elle nous a manqué personne n'a
jamais su quel était ce fameux problème
de sécurité qui justifiait de repousser
de six mois en six mois la décision de
garder ouvert de la maternité jusqu'à ce
qu'on nous annonce votre décision le 9
novembre 2016 de transformer le point au
1er janvier prochain la maternité d'apt
en centre périnatal et de renvoyer les
usagers vers cavaillon évidemment les
élus et notamment moi même l'avons
appris par la presse vous pouvez dans ce
cas parler de services publics d'accès à
la santé d'aménagement du territoire ou
rafraîchir la mémoire de la droite c'est
notre occasion aujourd'hui car cette
décision fait suite à la baisse du
nombre d'accouchements le manque de
gynécologues obstétriciens
mais après plusieurs années de régime de
suspicion sur la sécurité et d'ambiguïté
sur l'avenir d'une maternité comment ne
pas comprendre qu'une partie de la
population ait choisi d'éviter la
structure comment ne pas expliquer la
décision de jeunes médecins de ne pas
venir s'installer en ville je vous avais
proposé en en 2014 de créer un label
hôpital de montagne vous avez pris le 4
mars 2015 un arrêté ministériel relatif
au financement des activités de soins
répondant à des critères d'isolement
géographique
paradoxe la maternité d'apt ne figurent
pas alors que c'est sûr commune sur les
22 qui sont rattachés à ce territoire
rural à absente en zone montagne et par
constat d'huissier on réalise que les
trajets vont exposer par rapport au
nouvel établissement alors ma question
est simple si vous aimez le service
public allez-vous réexaminer votre
décision
analyser la possibilité d'inscrire
l'hôpital d'apt parmi les établissements
isolés géographiquement la parole et or
dame ségolène neuville secrétaire d'état
chargé des personnes handicapées de la
lutte contre l'exclusion le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député julien et vert je
vais répondre au nom de la ministre de
la santé marisol touraine et mais force
est de vous apporter des réponses
précises en dehors de toute polémique le
gouvernement est très attaché aux
établissements de santé de proximité et
donc à l'hôpital d'apt pour une raison
simple c'est qu'il s'agit d'accès aux
soins pour une grande partie de nos
concitoyens c'est la raison pour
laquelle de façon très récente avec
l'organisation du groupement hospitalier
de territoire
les activités d'urgence de chirurgie
mais aussi de smur ont été durablement
sécuriser et pérenniser dans votre
hôpital et c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
les populations
concernant la maternité à la demande des
élus locaux il y a eu effectivement une
expertise demandée à deux professeurs de
médecine et leur expertise a
effectivement conclu à un défaut de
sécurité pour les femmes et malgré
l'ouverture de candidature dans le cadre
du j'ai acheté pour des gynécologues
obstétriciens
il n'y a pas eu de réponse à ces
candidatures donc la décision a été
prise d'ouvrir un centre de périnatalité
de proximité à partir du 1er janvier
2017 ou les femmes pourront faire suivre
leur grossesse et ensuite après leur
accouchement
marisol touraine a décidé d'attribuer un
million d'euros à votre hôpital pour
justement permettre la modernisation des
installations
mais je dois dire que je me demande
comment vous pensez vous y prendre avec
le programme que vous avez parce qu'en
réalité vous prévoyez de supprimer 500
milles pioneer s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît et infirmiers a livré à l'hôpital
public je me rends bien d'être soignants
allez vous supprimez à l'hôpital public
et puis il ya une autre question qui me
qui me revient à l'esprit parce que
sincèrement quand vous dites quand votre
champion dit que désormais les
consultations classiques ne se non plus
être remboursé par la sécurité sociale
eh bien comment fera-t-on pour
rembourser les gynécologues aller